For the new builder,
what are some resources
that you would point them towards,
whether it's a journey
in tactile fashion industry
or a journey in engineering?
Like I just think like Claude,
go ask Claude a question
and it will break
it down for you.
Like I've started
doing Solana programs,
which I've never done before.
I just talk
with Claude through everything,
like not necessarily
have it make the code,
like something just after that,
when you're doing stuff
with smart contracts.
I would highly recommend
not by coding those,
but just being able
to understand it
and have Claude break it
down for you is incredibly...
It's so useful.
I wish I had that
back in the day.